[Musik]
[Applaus]
riad und washington sind alte verbündete
doch spätestens seit sich die usa 2010
unter barack obama den iran ernährten
begannen sich die beziehungen zum
saudischen königreich zu verschlechtern
der iran und saudi arabien sind nun mal
die beiden miteinander konkurrierenden
muslimischen platzhirsche in der region
unserem stelle der pakt vor schenkens
mit der heranführung nichts weniger als
einen verräter und seither hat sich die
lage trotz einiger bemühungen der
regierung weiter verschlechtert der
jüngste grund dafür ist die russische
invasion in der ukraine vor allem weil
siri hat beharrlich weigert die us
amerikanischen sanktionen gegen moskau
zu unterstützen aber warum um alles in
der welt unterstützt saudi arabien
weiterhin russland obwohl es dadurch
seine alten beziehungen zu den usa
gefährdet warum haben sich die
beziehungen zwischen riad und washington
seit 2014 so sehr verschlechtert was ist
von der alten freundschaft zwischen
diesen beiden ländern übriggeblieben
kann ist schon beiden gelingen das
verhältnis wieder zu kitten warum ist
gerade dieses getrübte verhältnis rias
zu washington und moskau so bedeutend
für die explosion der energiepreise und
warum könnte eine notierung dieser
verhältnisse auch die lösung der
europäischen energieprobleme einläuten
nun in diesem video beantworten bei all
diesen fragen aber zuerst begegnete uns
auf eine zeitreise zu den anfängen
dieser schon historisch
außergewöhnlichen beziehung
eine schrecklich nette beziehung
[Musik]
washington und riad sind miteinander
verbindet seitdem sich präsident
roosevelt 1045 mit dem saudischen könig
eben sound am suezkanal traf damals
besiegelten sie den sogenannten öl für
verteidigung packt danach hielten die
usa günstiges öl und garantierte nennt
gegenzug die sicherheit des saudischen
königreich und vor allem den
machtanspruch des königshauses haut das
war der beginn einer langen freundschaft
die große bedeutung für den weiteren
verlauf der weltgeschichte gewinnen
sollte doch es handelte sich nicht um
den ersten kontakt zwischen den beiden
ländern bereits wenige jahre nach der
gründung des jüdischen staates erhielt
rockefellers ändert old company 1933 die
konzession dort neue ölfelder
erschließen zu können so wurden nach und
nach einer beziehungen zwischen den
beiden staaten geknüpft
[Musik]
142 richteten die usa die erste
delegation in dschidda ein die 19 49 zu
einer botschaft aufgewertet wurde könig
ebenso persönlich drängte die usa 944
ein konsulat in tehran zu eröffnen dort
sollten us-bürger betreut werden die bei
der rlb american old company der
heutigen saudi aramco beschäftigt waren
1943 lud er die vereinigten staaten ein
ein flugplatz in daran zu bauen in die
us luftwaffe bis 1962 unterhielt und r n
go ist heute übrigens das wertvollste
unternehmen der welt es ist ein so
gewaltiges imperium das in sogar ein
eigenes video gewidmet haben dass ich
euch selbstverständlich verlinken werde
mit der es nicht verpasst aber zurück zu
unserer geschichte man verstand sich so
gut dass die usa 944 das landesprogramm
auf saudi arabien ausdehnen so dass die
saudis eine riesige menge an
rüstungsgütern auf den us waffen markt
kaufen konnten und kurz darauf 1951
unterzeichneten beide staaten ein
abkommen über gegenseitige verteidigungs
helfer in diesem rahmen wurde zum
beispiel die erste us militär
ausbildungsmission im saudischen
königreich eingerichtet aber so offen
und dankbar dass alles auch klingt so
misstrauisch man in saudi arabien auch
immer gegenüber der amerikanischen
presse und umgekehrt waren in usa
misstrauisch gegenüber den saudis die
gründe der große kultur der unterschied
und wirtschaftliche sowie nicht zuletzt
strategische interessen
das saudische regierung schwer die
stationierung von einer halben million
us soldaten während des ersten
golfkriegs zu akzeptieren und während
der invasion afghanistans nach dem 11
september 2001 erlaubten die saudis den
amerikanern schon nicht mehr ihr
territorium für militärische operation
zu nutzen auf der anderen seite
verurteilten die usa die saudische
beteiligung am sechstagekrieg haben
bürgerkrieg im jemen und die ambivalente
rolle des audis den kampf gegen den
terror
[Musik]
die liebe ziel war aber auch über das
strategische hinaus oft ambivalent aber
wären zum beispiel die beiden öl embargo
steve o thou die arabien oder 67 auf dem
sechs tage krieg 1973 nach den
arabisch-israelischen krieg verhängt
wurden vor allem das zweite juli embargo
richtete in den usa und auch weltweit
verheerende wirtschaftliche folgen an
die analysten damals die grosse
ölpreiskrise aus wie ihr seht reden wir
also eher von einer zweckehe denn von
einer liebesheirat die besondere
beziehung zwischen riad und washington
war in den letzten jahrzehnten ein
wichtiger bestandteil der us
aussenpolitik und dennoch war sie immer
auch von missverständnissen bedenken und
misstrauen geprägt
[Musik]
tatsächlich pflegen andere länder am
persischen golf viel engere beziehungen
zu den usa so perlak bahrain die
fünftgrößte us flotte kurven ex tausende
von us-soldaten auf stützpunkten von den
parteien unterhalten die usa 1996 mit
dem stützpunkt alpen date einen der
wichtigsten us luftwaffenstützpunkte
weltweit mit trump im weißen haus
konnten sich die dinge jedoch verbessern
der ehemalige präsident des design
qualität im nahen osten zu nachteil
kataris aus saudi arabien auch wenn das
den weggang seines außenministers rex
tillerson zur folge hatte und obwohl
katar ein sehr enger verbündeter
washingtons ist doch obwohl es während
dieser zeit eine annäherung zu geben
schien hat joe biden mit seinem
amtsantritt die räder wieder
zurückgedreht
[Musik]
dies sehen die aktuelle beiden regierung
als nachfolgerin der obama-regierung
letztere besiegelte nicht nur das
abkommen mit den iran sondern
unterstützte auch den arabischen
frühling und beides schmeckte der
saudischen regierung damals noch unter
könig abdullah wenig zudem hat beiden
das saudische regime nach der grausamen
ermordung der journalistin jamal
cascioli massiv kritisiert beiden ging
sogar soweit saudi arabien als paria
staat zu bezeichnen aber aufgepasst
liebe personalpolitik zuschauer die
probleme in der beziehung zwischen riad
und washington reichen noch tiefer
der künftige könig mohamed bin hammam
kurz mbs breit einen großen wandel im
land voran er modernisiert dem
mittelalter nicht vermuten monarchie auf
der halbinsel in nie gesehenen ausmaß
trotzdem genießt er bei den amis kein
besonders hohes ansehen man hält ihn
dort für zu impulsiv und wenig
vertrauenswürdig und dafür gibt es auch
gute gründe
[Musik]
in washington hat man verstanden dass
sich mit dem auftreten des grundrissen
das machtgefüge nassauischen hof
grundlegend verändert hat und zwar nicht
zugunsten der usa so wirkt er gegen
deren willen auf eine beteiligung am
jemand kriegen forderte den mord an
karubi an und versuchte zu allem
überfluss auch noch die usa mit seiner
politik zu erpressen ganz zu schweigen
von seinem stillen putsch im jahr 2017
als er den grund prinzen mohammed bin
naif stürzte und inhaftierte letzterer
verstand sich sehr gut mit den usa vor
allem wegen des gemeinsamen kampfes
gegen al kaida soviel zur achse riad wo
schinken aber wie lässt sich eigentlich
all diese verstimmung erklären warum ist
der ursprüngliche geistes der verbindung
beider staaten verfügen sollten beide
länder nicht er weiterhin voneinander
profitieren in so wichtigen bereichen
die energie innerer sicherheit und
verteidigung
[Applaus]
nun liebe zuschauer das blatt hat sich
in den letzten jahren radikal gewendet
die usa brauchten schlicht kein
saudisches öl mehr warum sollte man also
noch so viel in eine oberflächliche
zweck freundschaft investieren mit einer
gottes staatliche orientierten monarchie
ohne innere verbundenheit gefühl und
gemeinsamen wertekanon beute machen die
exporte in die usa weniger als fünf
prozent der saudischen rohöl exporte aus
der größte teil der saudischen öls wird
inzwischen nach fernost verkauft
insbesondere in länder wie china japan
südkorea und taiwan
alleine die ausfuhren nach china machen
mehr als doppelt so viel aus jene in die
usa
diese epochale wende im welthandel ist
kaum zu überschätzen die stiefel
revolution in nordamerika hat washington
dazu gebracht den nahen osten insgesamt
weniger bedeutung beizumessen nun ja das
war zumindest der stand der dinge bevor
russland in die ukraine eingefallen ist
denn diese erneute wende könnte die
verhältnisse nochmals ordentlich
durcheinanderwirbeln
es geht wieder einmal ums liebe geld
da haben wir also den neuen großen
wendepunkt der geschichte dachten viele
noch vor kurzem dieser wäre die korona
krise gewesen hatten sie ihre rechnung
ohne lange putin und shipping gemacht
der neue kalte krieg ist da um zu
bleiben und alle müssen wieder farbe
bekennen selbst die neutrale schweiz hat
diesmal klar stellung bezogen doch real
hat sich immer wieder geweigert moskau
für die völkerrechtswidrige invasion in
der ukraine zu verurteilen ganz im
gegenteil hat saudi arabien seine
unterstützung für russland in der
erweiterten opec deutlich gemacht in der
sogenannten opec plus während das weiße
haus eine kampagne anführte und
russlands und soli an produziertem an
den rat also weiter schlagzeilen wie
diese hier
saudi arabien signalisierte
unterstützung für russlands rolle in der
opec plus zu wehren dass sanktionsdruck
zunimmt und was noch viel schlimmer ist
für die interessen der usa saudi arabien
hat sich beharrlich geweigert seine öl
fördermenge zu erweitern um die preise
auf dem weltmarkt zu drücken dies hätte
die russischen einnahmen aus dem
ölgeschäft gemindert und gleichzeitig
die folgen der sanktionen für den westen
gemildert sanktionen welche zur sammlung
der kriegsangst die hohe öl und
gaspreise auf den höchsten stand seit
mehr als einem jahrzehnt getrieben haben
aber natürlich hat nur in riad seine
gründe für dieses handeln gründe die
durchaus nachvollziehbar sind
saudi arabien ist nach wie vor der
größte erdölexporteur der welt und da
der brent-preis war über 100 dollar pro
barrel liegt fließt ihr reichlich geld
in die saudische kassen das ist für das
königreich ernorm wichtig und bringt ist
in einer stärkere stellung gegenüber den
usa und saudi arabien steht vor einer
sagen wir mal komplizierten zukunft
einerseits ist seine bevölkerung sehr
jungen und gleichzeitig an einen relativ
hohen lebensstandard gewöhnt ohne selbst
viel leistung bringen zu müssen
andererseits reichen die öleinnahmen auf
dauer nicht mehr aus um den wohlstand
dieser ständig wachsenden verwöhnten und
globalen nicht deswegen bevölkerung zu
sichern die gesamte saudische
volkswirtschaft ist immer noch zu
abhängig vom schwarzen gold dann bist du
in saudi arabien angestellter so
arbeitest du weiterhin entweder für die
regierung oder für die ölindustrie
da ist es nicht schwer zu verstehen dass
das nicht eben ein zukunftsmodell sein
kann
die regierung in sanaa hat das erkannt
und will die situation ändern zum
beispiel plänen wieder so genannten
vision 2030 dieser agenda ist derart
gewaltig und auch geopolitisch bedeuten
dass wir sie bald präparates video
herausbringen werden vergesst also
beträgt das abo und ganz wichtig auch
nicht das glöckchen um es auf gar keinen
fall zu verpassen heute werden wir euch
über mbs agenda allerdings schon so viel
verraten dass eine ära hauptpunkte darin
besteht dass das land zu ihrer umsetzung
viel geld benötigt und zwar sehr sehr
viel geld das problem finanziell gesehen
waren die letzten jahre eher mager für
das königreich zwischen 2015 und 2020
hat der verfall der ölpreise dazu
geführt dass der saudische staat einen
großen teil seiner geldreserven
verbrauch musste wir sprechen hier von
hunderten von milliarden dollar die
plötzlich im staatshaushalt ein loch das
die saudis nah an den finanziellen
abgrund geführt hat aber das hat sich
inzwischen geändert die die höhe
geschossenen ölpreise bedeuten dass
saudi arabien die chancen hat seine
reserven wieder aufzustocken und
frisches geld zu investieren
die unerwarteten gewinn aufgrund der
hohen ölpreise werden wesentlich in die
resilienz unserer wirtschaft investiert
ob es nun darum geht reserven
aufzufüllen schulden zu tilgen oder über
unseren wohlstand vor ein einmaliges
transformationsprojekte zu investieren
das alles hilft uns wirklich unsere
diversifizierung pläne zum beschleunigen
eishalle ibrahim saudi arabiens minister
für wirtschaft und planung das aktuelle
preisniveau stellt für saudi arabien
einen derartigen glücksfall da dass man
dort sogar überlegt aktien des eigenes
saudischen ölkonzerns aramco zu
verkaufen die alcoa-aktie es seit putins
überfall auf die ukraine in die höhe
geschossen und hat zum zeitpunkt des
drehs dieses video sogar apple als
wertvollstes unternehmen der welt
abgelöst natürlich deuten die
verkaufspläne darauf hin dass man den
rat nicht mit dauerhaft hohen
energiepreisen reichte dies die
weltwirtschaft einfach nicht her sollte
der derzeitige kostendruck mittelfristig
nicht nachlassen wird er einerseits zu
einer schweren weltweiten rezession
führen und andererseits die globale
ökonomie noch schneller aus den fossilen
energieträgern heraus treiben es handelt
sich also um ein spiel mit dem feuer das
die weltwirtschaft am laufen hält und je
doller es die energie möchte mit ihrer
verknappung treiben desto schlimmer wird
der kater nach dieser großen partie
ausfallen ihr absturz wird aber heftig
sein sondern mit der früheren abkehr vom
öl und gas auch dauerhaft
dessen ist man sich in riad bewusst
versucht aber trotzdem abzugreifen was
geht allein im jahr 2022 hat das land
voraussichtlich mehr als 280 milliarden
us dollar durch den verkauf einnehmen
rund 180 milliarden dollar mehr als in
den vorjahren
und wenn die weltweite unterstützung für
russland weiter abnimmt könnten die
einnahmen des audis auch weiter so regel
sprudeln denn wenn die russischen
exporte sinken könnten alle anderen
vielleicht sogar noch mehr öl fördern
ohne dass die preise wesentlich fall das
ganze selbst schon wie ein
lehrbuchbeispiel aus der spieltheorie
denn wenn sich das königreich hierfür
die richtigen tür entscheidet könnte es
weitere drei oder vier jahre lang
ausserordentliche einnahmen verbuchen am
ende würden mehr als 500 oder 600
milliarden dollar aus den moe nächster
weltbevölkerung in die kassen des audis
gespült werden eine summe mit der die
wirtschaftliche diversifizierung screen
des landes extrem beschleunigt werden
könnten die zukunft der saudischen
volkswirtschaft könnte damit gesichert
werden so weit zumindest die theorie
aber heißt dies denn dass saudi arabien
die usa bald überhaupt nicht mehr
braucht was meint ihr sollten wir uns
diese frage an der sich der derzeitige
energie preispoker entscheiden könnte
nicht mal näher ansehen ich finde ja
also auf geht's
man soll den tag nicht vor dem abend
loben
[Musik]
auch wenn die usa nicht nur eine so
wichtiger kunde sind und riad inzwischen
andere prioritäten hat ist die beziehung
zu den amerikanern so dass haushalte
nach wie vor unverzichtbar so sehr es
mohammed bin salman auch schmerzt die
ubisoft sind für saudi arabien nach wie
vor verdammt wichtig denn sie sind nicht
nur weiterhin die heimat global
bedeutenden banken und versicherungen
und unternehmen sondern saudi arabien
hat auch selbst kräftig in die
amerikanische wirtschaft investiert im
rahmen der anstrengungen ihre wirtschaft
vom ölwechsel diversifizieren haben die
sagen wir es so mehr als 800 milliarden
dollar in den usa investiert verglichen
mit weniger als 100 milliarden dollar in
china gut man könnte man vielleicht
denken dass dies ein schwachpunkt der
usa darstellen würde denn was passiert
wenn saudi arabien sein geld nehme und
damit einfach woanders hingehen nun das
wäre aber gar nicht so einfach saudi
arabien will sein auf öl monokultur
ausgerichtete wirtschaft diversifizieren
und benötigt dafür unbedingt die
unterstützung der großen multinationalen
us konzerne außerdem ist es für die
petrom monarchie nicht einfach einen
anderen ort zu finden an dem sie so
große geldbeträge mit so großer
sicherheit und liquidität anlegen könnte
die verluste im fall einer
desinvestition während für die saudis
exorbitant oder gar existenzgefährdend
aber das ist nur die wirtschaftliche
perspektive vom militärischen standpunkt
aus gesehen ist die abhängigkeit sogar
noch größer
die saudischen streitkräfte stark auf
die us militär industrie und deren
technik fokussiert so flossen zwischen
2015 und 2019 73 prozent der saudischen
militärausgaben anflug des unternehmens
zwischen 2008 und 2020 gaben die saudis
über
145 milliarden dollar für us waffen aus
dabei handelt es sich aber nicht nur um
einen puren freundschaftsdienste araber
an die amis sie wissen dass sie für die
wirksame abschreckung ihrer regionalen
gegner deutlich überlegen oder
waffensysteme brauchen und diese
bekommen sie eben weder aus russland
noch aus china denn wenn der russische
kriegen der ukraine etwas bestätigt hat
dann genau diese harte tatsache nur die
usa und ihre verbündeten sind in der
lage wirklich moderne waffen in
ausreichenden stückzahlen zu liefert und
in erst fall auch zu versorgen dennoch
es ist richtig dass riad seit dem
russischen angriff auf die ukraine in
eine deutlich stärkere position
gegenüber den usa gekommen ist denn die
vereinigten staaten brauchen derzeit
wieder erdöl und zwar gleich in
doppelter hinsicht zum einen braucht man
öl auf dem eigenen markt um die
inflation einzudämmen
zum anderen gilt es die reine
amerikanischen bündnispartner gegen
russland geschlossen zu halten denn es
steigt der ölpreis weiter kann es
passieren dass einige staaten ihre
sanktionen gegen russland wieder
aufheben um an günstige energie für ihre
wirtschaft und ihre wahl volk zukommen
denn vergesst nicht diese probleme
werden um so drängen derweil in den usa
die nächsten wahlen ins haus stehen eine
weiter anhaltende hohe inflation und
insbesondere hohe preise an der tanke
könnt und das ergebnis und die
demokraten sondern noch größeren
debatten machen als er ist ohnehin schon
aussieht und vor diesem hintergrund hat
joe biden kürzlich einen besuch im
ehemaligen karstadt audi arabien für
mitte juli angekündigt
angesichts seiner starken worte aus der
vergangenheit sprechen manche bereits
von einem kniefall vor den saudis nun
man mag daran halten was man möchte
allerdings rein pragmatisch betrachtet
hat er wirklich guten grund dazu denn
empirisch schlägt eine veränderung des
rohölpreises um zehn dollar mit etwas 25
bis 30 cent auf den preis einer gallone
benzin durch grund jeder cent um den der
durchschnittlichen preis in den usa
steigt wird von mehr als einer milliarde
dollar an zusätzlichen kulturausgaben
unbemerkt pro jahr mit anderen worten es
geht und sich milliarden dollar welche
die us unternehmen und verbraucher mit
steigenden ölpreis verlieren könnten und
wenige monate vor einer mehrheit
entscheidenden wahl zu stehen während
dessen die benzinpreise durch die decke
gehen unternehmens sich milliarden
verlieren und die wirtschaft ins trudeln
gerät das ist in einer autofahrer und
gas gas la nation einem land der
unbegrenzten benzinschlucker fast schon
ein todesurteil
eine wahlniederlage ist da schon
vorprogrammiert um es ganz vorsichtig
auszudrücken oder um es mit bill
clintons worten zu sagen as the economy
stupid wahlen gewinnt man in den usa mit
der wirtschaft nicht gegen sie und
niemand weiß das besser als bottrop
außerdem dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass
saudi arabien ein wichtiger partner in
der us sicherheitspolitik für den nahen
osten er ist auch wenn es in den letzten
jahren tendenziell etwas an bedeutung
verloren hat so ein partner ist aber
genau das was die usa aktuell brauchen
um die hände frei zu haben für ihren
wichtigeren politischen militärischen
und wirtschaftlichen ziele denn die
liegen immer mehr im asiatisch
pazifischen raum
saudi arabien ist für uns ein wichtiger
partner im umgang mit dem extremismus in
der region im umgang mit den
herausforderungen durch den iran und ich
freue mich schon darauf den prozess des
aufbaus von beziehungen zwischen israel
und seinen nachbarn fortzusetzen
entweder brinken us-außenminister die
bevorstehende reise beiden seen der
region zeigen ob die beziehungen wieder
aufgebaut werden können oder ob sie
nachhaltig geschädigt sind rea zumindest
hat zuletzt signalisiert dass es zu
einigen bereits sein könnte
saudi arabien ist bereit mehr öl zu
fördern wenn die russische produktion
durch die sanktionen sinkt es sieht also
eher danach aus dass die zahl wird mit
putin er teil eines großen pokerspiels
um die für seine vision 2030 benötigten
finanziellen und technologischen mittel
war nichts als eine affäre um den
wichtigeren langfristigen partner
eifersüchtig zu machen und weich wäre so
lassen um dann doch wieder brav in uncle
sam schoss zurück zu kehren wenn man
seine zu kalli bekommen hat wir werden
auf jeden fall am ball bleiben und euch
über alle wichtigen entwicklungen auf
dem laufenden halten schließlich handelt
es sich hierbei doch um eine
schlüsselfrage der derzeitigen
energiepreis krise denn eines dürfen wir
nicht vergessen wie vor 50 jahren liegt
auch heute die betonung auf preis denn
energieträger gibt es auf der welt nach
wie vor mehr als genug alles ist nur
eine frage des willens und des preises
aber jetzt seid ihr erst mal an der
reihe denkt ihr dass die beziehungen
zwischen saudi arabien und den usa sich
wieder verbessern werden sollten die usa
versuchen ihr altes bündnis zu stärken
oder sollte beiden an seinem alten kurs
festhalten welches angebot könnte er ins
hallmann machen damit dieser wieder für
eine entspannung an den energie versorgt
und in die notwendigen leistungen bei
den us midterms in die wahlurnen spült
wie viel wird sich das alles beiden
kosten lassen und welche rolle wird
augen aravind dadurch künftig in der
welt spielen wie immer sind auf eure
diskussionsbeiträge zu diesem thema im
kommentarbereich schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht noch etwas dabei
gelernt habe falls jahr gibt es mit
einem like das mit uns freuen und
vergesst nicht das abo und das glöckchen
damit keines unserer videos mehr
verpasst natürlich freuen wir uns auch
die derzeit über eine spende von euch
mittels hält dieses projekt
weiterzuführen den paypal link dazu
findet ihr in der bescheid buch oder dem
video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]